- You know I rant about Monday
and you hating it,
we've had iconic videos
I'm sure they're
doing something now
that's how they roll
about that situation.
I mean, the real question
I've been debating is
how do I tell you what to do.
Okay, cool, I'll yell
at you and say
if you hate your Monday
then you gotta change.
You only have one life,
this and that.
And people are like
but what do I do?
What are the steps?
I think one of the biggest steps
is just to break patterns.
Right, like, you just have to
call out tomorrow.
You have to call out Tuesday.
You have to create
a call out on Tuesday.
And you need to do something.
You either need to go
to some Goodwill stores,
buy some stuff and
post it on eBay
like we've talked about.
You need to reach
out to 5,000 people
on Twitter that
day that you admire
and ask them if you
can have a cup of coffee.
We've talked about that.
Some of you have
successfully done that with me
and Mark Cuban and
the craziest entrepreneurs
and famous people in the world.
So, maybe that's what you do.
Maybe on your call out Tuesday
you go and go to six
interviews for different jobs
that you've been holding off.
Maybe on your call out Tuesday
you go and visit your
grandmother or your dad
and have that conversation
that you've needed to have.
Whether that's I love you or
whether that's hey
I'm not gonna be pinned down
by your negativity any more,
I'm going to do it.
You know, motivation's
exciting but the practicality
of an execution is
even more important.
And so I sit here today
and I make this video
and I say it's a
call out Tuesday.
Call out of work tomorrow,
do not go to school tomorrow,
do not do what you
normally do tomorrow
if you hated today's Monday.
If you hated waking up today,
if you loved the weekend,
if you can't wait for Friday,
and do one of those four or
five things that I just told you
or the reverse.
Or the reverse.
Why don't you take
your kids out of school?
Your kids are not gonna remember
fourth grade
Tuesday English class
but taking them somewhere
just you guys
doing something fun
is something
they'll remember forever.
That's what I want to
do with this video.
I want to inspire
a call out Tuesday
then action.
I don't want to hear
that you slept in to 11:30
and just moped around and
ate some Fruity Pebbles.
Action that we just talked
about or something else,
leave a comment below with
what you're gonna do
on your call out Tuesday.
Wow.